[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit nouveaux débats dans le cadre du
second tour des élections municipales un
débat consacré ce soir à la ville de
villepreux où les habitants vont devoir
faire le choix le 28 juin prochain entre
trois listes et stéphane mirambeau
bonsoir vous êtes le maire sortant
candidat pour un troisième mandat avec
une liste divers droite ensemble allons
plus loin
valérie bambins soir bonsoir vous êtes à
la tête de la liste divers centres agir
tous pour villepreux jean baptiste à
monique bonsoir mon sort vous êtes à la
tête de la liste est diverse entrent
villepreux naturellement merci à tous
les trois et d'avoir accepté l
invitation alors en raison de la crise
sanitaire le dispositif comme vous le
voyez est un peu particulier sur la
forme puisque les candidats sont
derrière leur écran et non en plateau
mais par contre sur le fond rien ne
change comme lors du débat du premier
tour le temps de parole sera
chronométrée et sera affiché
régulièrement au cours de l'émission
elle ajoute également que vous pouvez
suivre ce débat sur l'antenne de radio
sensations sur le 98.4 dans les yvelines
alors avant d'entrer dans le vif du
début du débat combien je vous propose
de faire un point sur les enjeux de ces
élections dans la commune deux villes
proches également un rappel des
résultats du premier tour pour le second
tour des municipales à villepreux trois
listes seront en lice celle menée par
jean baptiste à monique arrivés en tête
lors du premier tour valérie ben mènera
la liste agir tous pour villepreux issu
de la fusion avec la liste de sylvie ce
vin montel enfin le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau était arrivé le 15
mars dernier en troisième position avec
ses onze mille habitants gilles preuve
fait partie de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2016 et devrait compter un
nouveau quartier à l'horizon 2025
après plusieurs mois de concertation le
projet central park avait été dévoilée
fin 2018
objectif créer une entrée de ville
urbaine et paysagère scénario choisi 250
logements et un grand parc urbain de 19
mille mètres carrés plusieurs candidats
souhaitent que ce projet soit gelée
autre thème qui s'invite dans la
campagne la santé ville prenez pas un
désert médical mais est situé dans une
zone d'action complémentaires selon la
rs l'offre de soins est jugée
insuffisante et pourrait être étoffée
avec la craie
d'une maison de santé autre enjeu la
redynamisation du centre ville et
notamment le développement des commerces
de proximité qui souffrent de la
concurrence des zones commerciales des
villes voisines de plaisir et des
clayes-sous-bois enfin quel avenir pour
le théâtre de villepreux l'établissement
culturel de 400 places ne propose plus
de spectacle depuis septembre dernier
plusieurs candidats souhaitent re
développer la culture dans la ville et
réhabiliter cet espace alors certaines
de ces thématiques seront évidemment à
développer au cours de l'émission mais
juste avant je vous propose un tour de
parole pour savoir comment vous abordez
ce second tour est ce que par exemple le
contexte actuel a changé quelque chose
dans cette deuxième phase du scrutin
pour cette première prise de parole nous
suivrons l'ordre qui nous a été
communiqué par la préfecture des
yvelines pour la conclusion sera dans
l'ordre inverse c'est vous qui débute et
stéphane mirambeau alors je le rappelle
en vous êtes le maire sortant candidat
pour un troisième mandat avec une liste
divers droite ensemble
allons plus loin comment vous abordez ce
second tour avec beaucoup de force
c'est vrai que les résultats du premier
tour n'ont pas été à la hauteur de mes
attentes de ce qu'il faut voir aussi
c'est que le contexte était extrêmement
particulier avec des gens qui avaient
fait le choix de rester chez eux
on sait très bien que le taux
d'abstention a été extrêmement fort la
crise maintenant elle est loin derrière
nous les choses s'arrangent le risque
aujourd'hui il est pratiquement nul il y
aura des mesures de sécurité évidemment
qui seront mises en oeuvre lors du
scrutin il y aura des masques qui est
des gens vont venir avec leurs masques
et on pense très sincèrement qu'ils
aient des résultats du premier tour
pourraient être corrigés en tout cas
c'est ce que je souhaite évidemment lors
de ce second tour le 28 juin prochain
veut toujours de la force d'énergie
motivation évidemment je pense comme les
autres candidats valérie ben vous êtes
directrice d'institut médico éducatif à
la tête de la liste agir tous pour vivre
heureux alors une liste différente du
premier tour puisqu'il ya eu fusion avec
la liste ville preuve pour tous menée
par sylvie saint-jean tél la même
question comment justement vous abordez
ce second tour
mais alors pour les raisons sanitaires
qui nous ont d'abord
vraiment bouleversée pendant ces trois
mois et moi je pense qu'on est loin d'en
avoir fini puisque maintenant on parle
de difficultés économiques le pays doit
repartir ça aura des impacts en fait
surtout les français donc voilà il ya
cette partie là où pour nous le chemin
reste à faire et on a vécu des choses
qui nous ont fait affiner notre projet
par rapport à ce qu'ont proposé au début
et puis d'une autre façon aussi donc
j'ai proposé à 6020 que nous faisons
noir lemieux liste pour pouvoir offrir
une réelle alternative aux villes
produire lors du second tour avec un
projet qui nous tient à coeur
l jean baptiste à monique vous êtes à la
tête de la liste villepreux
naturellement vous êtes également un
délégué départemental du modem est ce
que la situation actuelle a changé votre
vision peut-être pour ce second tour
n'ont pas changé foncièrement la vision
nous on avait un projet d'avenir à
projet de renouveau qui envisageait
plusieurs changements pour la ville
à un horizon assez long sur plusieurs
années on parlait d'un projet citoyen
pour la ville de demain dans le campagne
de premier tour c'est toujours
d'actualité
on s'est rendu compte à la fois avec le
confinement et rfo avec la crise
aujourd'hui qui nous percute que les
propositions comporter au premier tour
sont aujourd'hui encore cruellement
d'actualité que ce soit sur l'économie
les solidarités sociales ou même la
santé en revanche c'est vrai qu'on
aborde ce second tour avec beaucoup
d'humilité
il ya aussi les électeurs pour que les
candidats notamment aussi pour nous qui
ne se sont pas déplacés par crainte au
premier tour on espère les voir présents
dans le bureau vote le 28 juin prochain
évidemment on va ajuster certaines
choses dans notre projet parce qu'il ya
quelques ajustements à faire en raison
du nouveau contexte
avec la crise maintenant économique et
sociale qui est devant nous en revanche
voilà on arrive avec la même équipe avec
le même projet et une équipe unie qui
n'a pas changé qui est la même depuis le
mois de septembre juste avant de
développer le premier thème on va jeter
un coup d'oeil sur le temps de parole
stefan meierhans beau et valérie ben
vous êtes tous les deux à 44 secondes et
jean baptiste à munich vous êtes à une
minute 0 2 alors pour être
complémentaire par rapport aux débats du
premier tour que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
revoir sur notre site internet et bien
nous avons
quelques choix d'aborder d'autres thèmes
le premier la démocratie un thème qui a
notamment animé cette campagne 2020 des
municipales et que l'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans chacun de vos au
programme
stéphane mirambeau vous souhaitez
notamment à mettre en place le co2 vise
coffret nous expliquer en quoi cela va
consister tout à fait en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que depuis plusieurs années
la démocratie participative et est
devenu en fait un gros mot nous savons
bien maintenant et le coeur de tous les
programmes
tout simplement parce que les français
demandent non pas plus de démocratie
parce que si voir c'est qu'on est dans
un pays avec une des plus vieilles
démocraties au monde mais plus être plus
impliqué participer davantage aux
grandes décisions structurantes de la
ville c'est d'ailleurs ce qui avait été
dit lors du grand débat c'était quelque
chose qui est elle qui était remontée
assez fort nous voulons être beaucoup
plus impliqués et c'est tout à fait
normal puis dans un programme
k1 mais lui propose il ne fera pas tout
et il proposera par la suite des choses
qui n'étaient pas dans son programme de
ce que les électeurs souhaitent c'est
beaucoup plus impliqués tout au long de
la durée de ce mandat nous la licence en
langues plein répondons avec deux
propositions la première proposition
c'est le creusot ville
c'est exactement on reprend les mêmes
principes que le connais ce qui
fonctionne parfaitement bien c'est le
comité de développement de villepreux
qui regroupera les forces vives de la
ville des associations les acteurs
économiques les professions santé les
jeunes et et beaucoup de habitants qui
seront là avec nous ils ont un lien
extrêmement fort travaillant extrêmement
fort avec la municipalité 3 sachs
premièrement ils vont travailler avec
nous sur la feuille de route pour
définir par priorité de manière
extrêmement consensuelle en reprenant
l'idée du nom local sur la feuille de
route pour les projets d'investissement
la deuxième des chaussées toutes les
propositions structurante de la ville
nous leur demanderons leur avis et nous
étudierons leur avis et la troisième
chose c'est vraiment ce soit eux qui
nous apporte des propositions et qui
seront débattus directement en conseil
municipal et qui nous en place le cas
échéant il ya une deuxième proposition
des très importantes
on a vu que il ya des projets tous ceux
qui sont cristallisant c'est à dire
qu'il crée beaucoup de tensions entre
les habitants j'en cite deux
sans que central park on l'a vu dans les
différents enjeux c'est un projet que
nous avons que nous avons travaillé avec
tout le monde mais il semble qu'il y ait
encore des ddd des imprécisions et qu'il
faut qu'on creuse encore le projet est
la deuxième des choses j'ai été
extrêmement surpris de voir ça pendant
la campagne le sujet des logements
sociaux et comment nous pouvons traiter
les sujets des logements sociaux
il ya de ça a créé beaucoup de
discussions notamment au niveau des
réseaux sociaux
donc pour cela nous nous proposons
d'aller plus loin que eu une grande
participation au travers la mise en
place de référendum
régulier et sur les grands problèmes
structure lente de la ville pour que les
villes provient puisse réellement
affirmer leur choix et donc ils seront
consultés d'une manière très régulière
sur ses grands projets ils pourront
affirmer leur choix ils trancheront et
nous appliquons ce qu'ils souhaitent car
ça me concerne en tout premier lieu
valeur et ben vous souhaitez également
instauré à plus de démocratie
participative ou l'associé aussi le plus
grand nombre d'habitants aux décisions
publiques en quoi votre projet différent
de celui de monsieur mirambeau que
monsieur mirambeau vient de développer
par exemple mais que ce soit monsieur
mirambeau ou les adjoints qui ont
rejoint monsieur à munich on peut parler
pour eux n'ont pas de projet mais aussi
de bilan en démocratie participative
ici nous la liste nous nous sommes
montés c'était justement après le grand
débat national quand il ya débat sur
central park
on a trouvé que c'était tellement élu
est-ce que la façon dont ont été traités
en tant que citoyen que nous avons
décidé de nous mobiliser pour apporter
une alternative aux autres citoyens
donc nous notre projet nous important
depuis le début de la démocratie
participative moi dans ma carrière
professionnelle j'ai toujours travaillé
comme ça avec mes équipes
donc ça n'a jamais été un gros mot pour
moi entre un point ce que vous venez
bien monsieur mirambeau et puis tout
récemment bien dans le cadre du
confinement on a mis en place en fait
sur une page facebook un outil de
partage où les villes provient pouvaient
échanger sur leurs besoins ce qui
pouvait offrir et faire du lien entre
les gens voilà donc nous aussi quand on
parle de bilan deux des adjoints de
monsieur
monique et de monsieur mirambeau les
comités de quartier ont été supprimés
donc le conseil municipal de la jeunesse
a été supprimé donc tout ça c'était des
instances démocratiques qui existait
dans la ville et que nous souhaitons en
fait remettre en place les premiers et
dans ces quartiers dans ces comités de
quartier en fait l'idée ce serait non
seulement d'écouter les gens pensent
qu'ils ont des choses à faire savoir
mais aussi de revenir vers eux pour leur
faire une analyse en fait de la
situation budgétaire de la situation de
la commune pour avoir un réel dialogue
et leur donner des éléments d'analysé de
comparaison voilà donc sur la démocratie
participative
oui on la veut est ou non en la gemme
érige la jean baptiste à monique vous
voulez institué un conseil de la vie
locale ou souhaite également renforcer
le lien de proximité entre les villes
prose hien et les élus oui maintenant
mais je suis ravi de voir que les autres
candidats entre le premier et deuxième
tours se sont convertis du coup à la
démocratie de proximité et à la
participation citoyenne
c'est évidemment une team est une
thématique pour laquelle on plaide
depuis le début de cette campagne
d'ailleurs c'est la façon dont on fait
campagne depuis le début je rapelle que
au mois de novembre au mois de décembre
on a lancé une grande enquête me cale
citoyenne parce que d'autres considèrent
que la démocratie c'est pas uniquement à
ce scrutin tous les six ans qu'on a fait
l'effort d'aller voir les villes plaisir
de les écouter non pas comme je l'aï
entendu ou lu parce qu'on n'avait pas de
programme on a des convictions fortes on
a des idées fortes
mais je pense que c'est utile de
confronter ses idées d'aller sur le
terrain d'avoir des remontées du terrain
et d'écouter les gens pour savoir dans
quelle orientation aussi il faut aller
donc ça c'est à la fois la composante
même de notre de notre campagne cette
démocratie là évidemment on veut la
mettre en oeuvre pendant le mandat
je citerai quelques exemples villepoix
gora en à communiquer dessus assez tôt
dès notre annonce de candidature il
prague aura c'est quoi c'est un rendez
vous en rendez vous mensuel entre les
élus et les citoyens à disposition
chaque mois dans un quartier différent à
la fois pour informer sur vos projets en
cours les projets à venir mais aussi
comme je disais constamment pour avoir
ses remontées du terrain et pouvoir se
remettre en question dans l'action
publique élections municipales autre
sujet budget participatif financer des
projets qui sont portés par les acteurs
du terrain associations commerçants
particuliers par exemple
en revanche on parlait des petits
ajustements à de l'après crise ce budget
participatif
nous ne débuteront qu'à partir de
l'année
21 pour allouer les fonds qui étaient à
louer plutôt un soutien est là pour
bâtir un accompagnement des acteurs les
plus touchés par la crise après la
démocratie c'est aussi la démocratie au
sein du conseil municipal en est les
seuls ou 6,6 à avoir dit que nous
respecterions les droits de l'opposition
j'ai même proposé comme ça se fait
ailleurs que la présidence de la
commission des finances revienne à un
élu d'opposition je pense que c'est sain
pour la démocratie c'est aussi rendre
public en live les conseils municipaux
et avoir des compte-rendu exhaustif et
publics pour tous le premier conseil
municipal qu'on a eue de public était
celui de la semaine de la delà du mois
passé pendant le confinement et on sait
que ça a été très compliqué pour
l'obtenir donc en tout cas nous on
s'inscrit dans un véritable changement
de méthode sur ce sujet là qui nous est
chère depuis le tout début de la
campagne
quant à la remarque sur les anciens
adjoints je pense que madame vous êtes
un petit peu mal placé pour me faire ce
reproche alors que vous avez aujourd'hui
une fusion liste avec madame ce vin qui
était premier adjoint de me suivre un
bureau de monsieur virant venue du monde
2008 valérie parce que vous souhaitez
répondre à monsieur harmonique
non non on voit pas à l'oeil sur la
polémique je préfère qu'on parle des
projets alors vous êtes justement un
tout petit peu en retard on va jeter
vite fait un coup d'oeil sur sur le
temps de parole à stéphane mirambeau
vous êtes à trois minutes 28 3 minutes
21 pour jean baptiste à monique deux
minutes trente et un pour vous valérie
barras que je vous souhaitez justement
ajouter quelque chose pour pour ce thème
donc de la démocratie
ben ça doit être parce que je suis plus
directe et que je parle plus simplement
en tous les cas le budget participatif
puisque monsieur à monique l'a évoqué
une fille depuis le début on souhaite en
faire un élément pour motiver les villes
provient à la gestion de la ville et ça
sera un budget participatif assez
conséquent enlevé de la taille de 1 % du
budget pour pouvoir mener à bien des
choses concrètes qui vont vraiment
embellir la ville ou en tout l'état
faciliter la vie des villes provient
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on serait
de faire au dessus après tout le monde
écoute tout le monde en période de
campagne électorale
le tout après c'est de revenir avec des
propositions et travailler ses
propositions avec les gens et c'est ce à
quoi nous nous sommes employés puisque
nous sommes une liste citoyenne
nous avons fait tout ce chemin en neuf
mois et donc nous avons beaucoup écouté
et nous avons
ou à prix nous avons beaucoup travaillé
et nous avons noué une machine une
excellente relation avec les villes
provient voilà on peut dire qu'on a eu
l'équivalent d'un volume d'une d'un
millier de questionnaires aussi de
remplis par des interviews des échanges
des temps de réunion voilà donc d'abord
si beaucoup travaillé ce sujet là on
passe au deuxième thème qui est
l'économie et la dynamique locale un
thème qui prend on peut le dire tout son
sens au lendemain de la crise sanitaire
que l'on a connue qu'à notamment
fragilisé évidemment l'économie locale
alors justement qu'avez vous prévu de
mettre en place pour redynamiser le
centre-ville renforcer l activité
commerciale on va commencer avec vous
jean baptiste à monique sur sur
l'économie et sur l'économie locale
d'évoquer le centre ville s'est pas
uniquement la question du centre-ville
la question est on l'a bien vu là
pendant confinement et on le voit avec
un corps plus d'actualité lalancette
après crise
cet après crise sanitaire et en guise et
on disait tout suspense - partagent tous
aussi donc c'est clément que les temps
sont durs que à la fois sur le volet
social va découler des impacts
économiques de la crise
on va arriver dans des situations avec
des personnes qui vont se retrouver dans
des fragilité financière dans les
fragilité sociale qui à voir qu'ils vont
avoir besoin d'accompagnement au niveau
de l'économie locale nous c'est un
projet comporte pareil encore une fois
depuis le mois de septembre on en n'a
pas changé et ce sont les mêmes
personnes qui le porte
on a cette envie de remettre de
l'économie sur wimereux et là il y avait
des discours et a notamment monsieur le
maire qui avait ce discours toujours
assez fataliste de dire que le
développement économique n'était pas
pour la ville de l'épreuve le
développement économique la façon dont
elle entend nous avec la dispute pro
naturellement c'est pas un développement
économique à outrance avec des grands
centres commerciaux des grandes surfaces
etc évidemment pas ça c'est mettre des
économies aujourd'hui de demain
l'économie verte économie circulaire
l'économie sociale et solidaire
notamment dans l'aide à la personne qui
voit des sujets des thématiques très
développé dans cette après crise faire
en sorte de créer les conditions locales
pour faire venir des entreprises faire
venir des start up
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a ce projet
des espaces collaboratifs et se polit
cet espace de deux lieux de télétravail
on voit que le télétravail aujourd'hui
et non seulement à la mode mais devient
presque une nécessité sa hausse
vocation environnementale parce que ça
limite les déplacements domicile travail
très tôt dans la campagne on a
communiqué sur cette volonté de créer un
tel lieu on le fera
on envisage même de mettre un lieu
provisoire pour le télétravail
en attendant la création de celui là ça
va favoriser aussi des sanctions
d'écosystèmes locale parce que
contrairement à ce que certains peuvent
dire c'est pas en gagnant plus
d'habitants pour redynamiser en
centre-ville ou qu'on fait on faire
repartir l'économie c'est en créant de
nouveaux modes de consommation je pense
aux circuits courts
je pense aux congés locales et donc tout
ça nécessite de mettre en relation les
différents acteurs des associations des
professionnels les commerçants et
postiers de l'après crise je le disais
pourquoi aussi on a décidé de retarder
dans le temps ce budget participatif qui
serait de l'ordre de 35 à 40 mille euros
par an on souhaite aussi accompagné en
plus de ce que proposera la commération
les commerçants et des acteurs les plus
touchés par la crise une un dernier mot
parce que c'est très lié au volet
économique ces deux volets social on
réunira au mois de septembre l'ensemble
des acteurs sociaux de la commune alors
évidemment la municipalité mais les
associations qui oeuvrent dans ce
domaine également les entreprises pour
définir de nouvelles solidarités locales
parce que c'est un effort qui doit être
partagée que la colline ne peut pas tout
avec ma quête d'une terre très restreint
mais que le confinement nous a montré
notamment dans le portage de repas dans
la présence physique auprès des seniors
qu'il y avait énormément de choses à
réinventer et donc nous proposerons de
le faire avec les acteurs concernés et
qui sont à l'oeuvre sur ces sujets là
depuis longtemps
c'était fade mirambeau vous avez
notamment été interpellés par monsieur à
monique quels sont vos projets justement
pour renforcer l'activité commerciale à
vil prix
en introduction quel programme
quel programme et monsieur à moroni
qu'on n'est pas l'assemblée nationale
ici une étape dans une ville avec des
contraintes fortes et quand on lit votre
part est carrément un programme
l'intercommunalité est pratiquement et
même peut-être deux régions faut un peu
qu'on retrouve le sens de ce qu'est la
ville de villepreux déjà vous parlez de
développement éco de protection de
l'activité économique mais elle savait
peut être pas doublement économique est
une compétence qui est porté par saint
parres 50 ans oui je les lis ce
développement économique
il bénéficie directement et en premier
lieu à sète interco
pisa nations depuis sa création
l'intégralité des recettes issues de la
fiscalité professionnelle directement
dans le budget de cette intercommunalité
donc même si surville preuve vous
faisiez venir
airbus ou même openskies comme vous le
dis vous n'aurez aucun revenu
supplémentaire dans votre budget donc si
vous votre objectif dans un premier
temps parce qu'on a besoin de ça vous
vous dit que il n'ya pas que les
habitants pour faire rentrer des
recettes fiscales mais si vous vous
écartez les nouveaux habitants elle que
vous faites tout votre votre votre
objectif sur le développement économique
vous ne rentrerez aucune somme d'argent
supplémentaire le développement
économique soient vides quoi c'est pas
mettre des nouvelles entreprises c'est
voir qu'est ce qu'on demande en eau
ville comme la nôtre nous on doit
apporter autre chose par rapport
pascal sky c'est les gros entrepris si
le développement est connu on doit
apporter du bien vivre du mieux vivre
on doit apporter par exemple de cadre de
vie il notre environnement et tout ce
qui va faire que des entreprises et leur
personnel vous s'implanter sur le
territoire de scan et vous c'est quoi en
fait l'économie locale
c'est pas mon psy compte mesures qui
sont énormes graines en fait un
programme de votre de vos amis c'est
quoi c'est le commerce de proximité
parce que quand on tapait là c'est le
cas mais l'entraîneur blockhaus
d'habitants de se plaire et c'est ça
l'économie locale survie voilà c'est
cela et donc moi il ya deux mesures ça
j'en ai pas 25000 premièrement notre
création du milieu de vie par la
capacité de muter de l'école jacques
gillet on va faire venir du commerce de
proximité parce qu'il y aura enfin des
places de stationnement innombrables je
vous remercie d'avoir pris cette idée
d'ailleurs monsieur louis je n'ai pas
besoin de vous pour ça et donc on va
permettre enfin on va répondre enfin aux
attentes des habitants de ce quartier
parce qu'on va pouvoir mettre à
disposition ses commerces dans le centre
ville c'est la même chose il faut qu'on
renforce notre offre commerciale de
commerce de proximité
on a proposé de halle qui vont être
structurante au niveau 2 le centre ville
je vais pas de leçons à voir au niveau
budgétaire alors que vous nous avez
expliqué 50 mesures en l'espace de 30
secondes et donc il y aura deux halles
la première à l'on va enfin pérenniser
le marché en a besoin parce que le
marché il est en danger pour votre
marché autour on va permettre dans
l'autre al de tester des nouveaux
commerces qui vont être complémentaire
de ce qu'ils disent des commerces
éphémère qui vont apporter plus de vie
dans le centre-ville voilà madame en
quelques mots
est-ce que je peux me permettre le fera
alors juste un jeu juste après valérie
ben je laisse la parole à valérie bain
et vous pouvez réagir juste après
valérie blanc vous souhaitez notamment
remettre du lien entre la municipalité
et les commerçants
oui alors donc tout d'abord nous sur
notre liste nous avons des commerçants
des acteurs locaux donc nous nous le
vivons avec le au travers de nos
colistiers qui nous racontent leurs
difficultés et leur joie d'être aussi à
vis des bills provient parce que c'est
aussi ça qu'il faut retenir du
confinement
c'est que finalement c'est on avait des
boulangeries on avait une boucherie on
avait des des centres des petits stands
commerciaux de proximité on avait des
des journaux voilà donc finalement nous
si on a dit proulx on a bien pu vivre le
confinement c'est qu'il ya moins d'une
heure de distance à pied on pouvait se
ravitailler de l'essentiel
et puis effectivement les commerçants du
marché en sueur et adapter leur modèle
économique pour la plus grande
satisfaction des villes provient donc
moi je suis aussi d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut pérenniser ces commerces il
faut les aider il faut leur donner de la
visibilité est trouvé en fait tous les
moyens de leur donner toute leur place
c'est aussi pour ça que dans le cadre
des marchés publics en fait on souhaite
mettre une clause sur justement le
commerce local pour favoriser en fait
quand ils ont dans les moyens techniques
favoriser la participation des acteurs
locaux en fait à la vie économique de la
ville 1 par rapport à ça monsieur
mirambeau moi je suis ravi de vous
prévoyez dans un troisième mandat de
couvrir le marché en termes de priorités
je respecte et que ça devienne un petit
peu plus tôt puisque c'est effectivement
le marché c'est aussi un lieu de
rassemblement
et nous aussi nous souhaitons pouvoir
créer un lieu qui ne fait pas que marché
d'ailleurs mais qui permettrait de se
retrouver pardon on se retrouve là
dessus donc voilà ça doit être une bonne
idée alors un endroit en fait où on
pourrait aussi se retrouver pour faire
de la musique quand il fait pas trop
beau au mois de juin ou pour d'autres
événements des événements sportifs des
choses comme ça donc voilà ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui nous a
manqué et que l'on souhaitait faire
alors moi je suis aussi d'accord avec
vous monsieur mirambeau vous voyez tout
arrive c'est la sky qui porte le
développement économique de la
communauté d'agglo nous nous habitons
ici nous habitons à villepreux beaucoup
de gris produit un travail sur la
communauté d'agglo et je pense que c'est
aussi comme ça qu'il faut voir le tissu
économique
donc l'argent de fin mai les salaires
des salariés qui habitent à villepreux
doivent aussi dynamiser la vie
économique au niveau de la sky et à ce
moment là d'une façon indirecte
on en aura des retombées exactement
alors juste avant de d'abord de redonner
la parole à jean baptiste à monique on
fait juste un petit point rapide sur le
temps de parole stéphane mirambeau vous
êtes assis milieu de 37 jean baptiste à
monique six minutes trente et une six
minutes 05 pour valérie bat jean
baptiste à monique en 20 secondes vous
souhaitiez concordance c'était une
fusion 23 du coup vous auriez dû faire
ce que vous êtes d'accord sur tout nous
notre vision elle est totalement
différent vous êtes en train de nous
expliquer qu'il faut toujours plus
d'habitants pour redynamiser le centre
est pour justement favoriser le commerce
de proximité nous il faut créer des
conditions économiques favorables pour
que les commerces restent et quand on
parle d'un lieu de 3 2 des tno
télétravail c'est parce qu'on sait qu'il
ya deux villes provient sur trois
aujourd'hui qui sont en capacité de
faire un minima deux jours de
télétravail par semaine et donc si vous
les avez sur votre commune en journée en
semaine c'est comme ça que vous allez
recrue de la consommation quand vous
allez faire venir dans le centre-ville
où pareil parce qu'on a ce projet dans
une partie des codes jacques jules et
les produits de la map les produits des
agriculteurs du coin en bio notamment
pour du qualitatif lavours créer des
synergies locales et vous recréez du
dynamisme économique sur la ville j'ai
jamais parlé de l'open sky évidemment de
saint quentin a une compétence
économique mais ça veut pas dire que
parce que 50 à ses compétences qu'il ne
faut rien faire
mais qu'il faut laisser justement comme
vous l'avait dit et vous l'avez démontré
les boulangeries les petits commerces se
fermer depuis des années c'est pas du
tout quant à l'animation du centre-ville
dont on en a parlé et est toujours donné
tout premiers mois justement de notre
projet nous ne portons pas le projet
d'une halle
parce que monsieur rimbaud nous monsieur
mirambeau nous expliquent à longueur de
journée qu'il n'y a plus d'argent
aujourd'hui pour faire ce type de projet
est donc aujourd'hui il lui a trouvé en
jean baptiste air indique juste vaut
couper parce que sinon vous n'aurez plus
trop de temps pour l'autre thème et pour
la conclusion
alors je laissais répondre monsieur
mirambeau en 30 secondes si on pourra
aborder le dernier thème d'harmonie et
injuste avec son idée d'un espace de
coworking
il veut sauver les villes pro d1 on sort
et lorsqu'à surprenant c'est qu'on sort
de crise sanitaire il avait énormément
de ville provient qui ont fait du thé
les traces du télétravail en sang
d'autres équipements c'est pas une
curieuse est-ce que c'est pas en fait un
peu de poudre aux yeux que vous voulez
lancer lorsque vous pensez qu'ils ont
sous tutelle
chez eux en télétravail et si on adopte
maintenant mais rythme de travail qui
vont favoriser le télétravail
ça va être essentiellement en
travaillant plus tôt de chez soi qu'on
développement des zones partout qui
n'aura en fait aucun sens vu qu'on est
en train de changer un peu
l'organisation même du travail donc dans
ce cas là saint quentin en yvelines ne
porterait pas l'accompagnement aux
espaces de télétravail sur le théorisait
allait exploser votre temps de parole
monsieur à munich on va laisser répondre
valérie bas en 30 secondes sur ce thème
et puis après on passera au dernier
thème oui alors vous avez tous les deux
parlent et de l'école jacques gillet
pour moi ma vision c'est que un grand
bâtiment comme ça puisqu'il ya s'il ya
en fait une classe par niveau
ça doit être un centre de profit et non
pas une charge en y mettant la map ou ce
genre de choses il faut qu'on trouve un
moyen de reconversion de ce bâtiment qui
ne soit pas pour la commune cherche
supplémentaires comme c'est une école
qui destinent c'était une école destinée
aux enfants
moi je trouve ça intelligent de trouver
une reconversion en lien avec les
enfants c'est un bâtiment qui s'y prête
bien
alors puisque je suis dans le médico
social ça pourrait aussi pour des
enfants en situation de handicap ou
alors une école alternative
complémentaire à l'offre actuelle mais
sans rien
alors et pour le parking du village
puisque effectivement il ya un problème
de stationnement
nous avons aussi un projet qui qui ne
serait pas juste cette petite cour qui
finalement sera très vite trop petit
mais ça va mal ce dernier thème aussi
rappelle abordé juste un coup d'oeil sur
le temps de parole
non mais j'ai beaucoup on va papa ce
roman on va passer au dernier tms ne
pourra pas abordé le thème de la culture
puisque parmi les infrastructures à
villepreux il ya notamment à la
médiathèque le nautilus et puis il ya
également un théâtre qui est à l'arrêt
depuis plus d'un an justement quelles
sont vos propositions pour développer
redévelopper la culture habile preuve on
va commencer avec vous valérie bain
puisque vous êtes à 7 minutes 10
vous avez une minute une minute trente
pour parler de ce thème
voyez comme quoi les femmes elles
parlent de façon efficace
donc contrairement à ce que monsieur à
mo'nique a annoncé avec un budget de 700
mille euros ou monsieur à mirambeau si
vous avez été là dessus en disant que
l'ouverture du théâtre quand on en
parlait c'était au minimum un demi
million d'euros par an on savait très
bien qu'on avait les pales ces moyens là
et on n'a jamais imaginé qu'on nous ne
sommes pas des producteurs de spectacle
il nous avons jamais imaginé ce genre de
projet donc je voulais juste dire que
humblement nous ce qu'on souhaitait
c'est optimiser l'occupation de ce
théâtre au profit des villes provient
nous avons des associations nous avons
des jeunes qui font de la guitare dans
chez eux dans une cave dans leur chambre
etc et ils ont besoin d'avoir accès à
leur public et ils ont besoin de place
voilà donc ça il ya déjà des répétitions
de cours qui se font en théâtre
ça serait bien qu'ils puissent le faire
régulièrement
et puis la terre le théâtre mais c'est
aussi quand même dans quelques
spectacles et là on a encore la
communauté d'agglo de saint quentin on
doit quand même pouvoir arriver à faire
un maillage avec les autres salles de
spectacle de 50 ans
faudrait quand même expliquer pourquoi
c'est impossible donc ce théâtre on peut
le faire revivre sans pour autant avoir
des projets pharaoniques et puis la
culture c'est aussi autre chose
nous par exemple je pense que les fêtes
les journées à thème
les fêtes de fin d'année pour les
scolaires les bases légales à tout ça ça
fait partie de la culture et ça doit
être encouragé et là avec le tissu
associatif puisque nous avons quand même
plus d'une centaine d'associations sur
la ville beaucoup sont aussi porté sur
la culture
nous avons des talents parmi les villes
provient donc tout ça en fait ça peut se
faire de façon tout à fait raisonnable
et sans en fait gréve et le budget de la
commune c'était fade miron bon je vous
laisse répondre
en fait on est déjà loin de l'idée de
sylvie se vendent donc non mais je suis
ravi que le 7 juillet suivant distance
at il beaucoup l'idée qu'ils soient
plutôt laissé de côté on est loin de la
mise à disposition pendant l'année
complète à des professionnels
producteurs du privé qui serait venu
pour absolument rien comme argent sur la
ville donc je ne sais pas de quoi vous
parlez
changez vaste estimé bon c'est plutôt
curieux vous êtes vous avez écris moi je
dirais techniquement sur sur le tracteur
vous avez décrit exactement ce que nous
faisons depuis plusieurs années ses
pattes le théâtre il est à l'arrêt comme
gelé ou conduite c'est que depuis
plusieurs années il est mise à
disposition environ trois mois pour
65000 euros par an avec les aides du
fonds de concours de saint quentin est
justement ce que vous avez dit il est
mis à disposition d'associations unies
mis à disposition au niveau des écoles
au niveau du collège et on peut même
faire des spectacles supplémentaires
dans une enveloppe budgétaire qui passe
c'est plate de 65000 euros mais moi je
suis totalement d'accord avec vous si on
peut simplement se mettre d'accord moi
je ne suis pas opposé et il voit plutôt
d'un bon oeil de se dire comment est ce
qu'on peut optimiser encore plus les
choses en allant par exemple sont à 2
septembre
sur le mois d'octobre pour encore
renforcer notre offre 4 théâtrale et
notre offre culturelle au niveau de cet
équipement mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'il faut respect dans des contraintes
budgétaires on n'est plus du tout dans
l'essonne que j'avais entendu avant le
15 mars
et si plutôt très très bien je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous je pense
qu'une enveloppe budgétaire n'est à 65
milles seront à 1000 euros dans votre
budgétaire maximum de soins 1000 euros
soit acceptable je pense que le lustre à
80 millions pour remettre encore un
petit peu mais je suis complètement fed
en fasse dieu que vous proposez ce que
j'ai mis en place depuis plusieurs
zahn et en rajoutant quelques spectacles
conclut je suis totalement en phase avec
vos mains ah bon excusez mentonnais
monsieur jean-dominique ne s'est pas
encore exprimé sur ce thème monsieur
meunier vous avez une petite minute pour
jouer les mécènes c'est exceptionnel de
voir à quel point les programmes ont
changé entre le premier et le second
tour
chez mes concurrence et c'est vraiment
bon mais très bien mais les villes
président obama et coûté en tout cas
sûre sur le projet sur le théâtre
on l'a dit mais met très tôt que cet
équipement évidemment été un équipement
auquel les produits sont très attachés
il n'a jamais été question de mettre par
terre on n'a jamais parlé d' ouverture
annuelle jamais pour parler de
l'ouverture saisonnière ponctuelles en
développement certains animations
remettons un ciné club qui est parce qu
il ya plus coûteux en créant des
synergies avec les associations avec les
acteurs locaux
quand on a ce projet justement de
l'école de musique et des arts à jacques
gillet c'est aussi pour créer un
partenariat avec l'école de musique donc
cesser refaire vivre ce théâtre qui
n'est pas fermée il faut le dire
je rappelle qu'il n'a fermé madame ben
vous le savez très bien elle est sur
notre liste
donc il faut arrêter de faire croire
qu'on va pouvoir ouvrir cet équipement
toute l'année donc je suis content de
vous l'entendre dire aujourd'hui à 1 - à
une semaine du second tour vous allez
donc changé de positions radicalement et
deux ans et il faut surtout pas c'est ça
que je veux dire s'il faut surtout pas
résumer la politique culturelle de la
commune à ce seul équipement aujourd'hui
vous avez à plaisir et aux
clayes-sous-bois des théâtres l'espace
coluche espace philippe noiret il faut
savoir vivre avec son temps il ne faut
pas penser qu'on va pouvoir avoir le
même type de programmation à villepinte
dans ces communes là ce serait pas mal
instamment ni comme si vous continuez on
aurait besoin et - datant pour la
conclusion
nous serons dans l'accompagnement des
acteurs nous allons avoir une vraie
politique culturelle nous en parlons
dans le programme je laisse aller vite
posé à reprendre de connaissance parce
que nous nos propositions sont très
claires merci jean baptiste abonné aux
foreurs et projetant sinon pour la
conclusion cette émission touche
beaucoup de propositions il leur est
alors messieurs messieurs mirambeau on
va passer à la congressional on va
passer à la conclusion que l'émission
touche bientôt à sa fin
il vous reste à peu près une minute pour
pour conclure ou aborder une thématique
de votre choix
en évitant les attaques personnelles
puisque vous ne pourrez pas vous
répondre puisque les laissions touche à
sa fin on va suivre l'ordre inverse du
début on va donc commencer par vous jean
baptiste à monique bon alors en
conclusion nous évidemment en se
mobilisent pour que les villes projets
qui nous ont placés en tête avec 39% des
voix au premier tour transforme l'essai
le 28 juin prochain
notre programme n'a pas changé notre
équipe n'a pas changé et je voulais en
deux mois à bord d une thématique qui
est prioritaire et qui sera prioritaire
pour nous si nous sommes égaux lendemain
tu vas tu juin c'est la rentrée scolaire
avec des grands enjeux des grands on a
le retard de l'école des vieux-moulins
on a un contexte la vente d'ing donc on
sait très bien qu'il ya aussi un
problème d'effectif et de sureffectif
dans certaines classes je suis assez
attristé de voir que certains candidats
récupère cela en à l'entracte et dans
devant les écoles c'est dommage en tout
cas nous nous avons interpellé les élus
sur deux pistes les autorités
compétentes et la rentrée scolaire
je me dis oh ville provient ce sera la
priorité nous travaillons déjà dessus
il faudra la réussir c'est un préalable
indispensable c'est le sujet du moment
et je profite pour souhaiter bon courage
à tous ceux qui vont devoir reprendre le
22 juin parce que c'est jean baptiste
elle prépare t et quand même et que même
problématique mans en tout cas voilà à
mousser jean-baptiste à moins 10 je suis
obligée de passer avaler les bains
valérie ben vous avez une minute trente
pour conclure aborder un thème de votre
choix oui bon bah écoutez moi ce que je
souhaiterais dire aux villes provient
c'est que j'apporte un nouveau style en
fait de gestion et de gouvernance de la
ville voilà quelque chose de plus apaisé
dans l' écoute donc
j'apporte du coût du changement en fait
sur ce sur ce plan-là je suis je suis je
gère des budgets en fait depuis très
longtemps donc j'ai vraiment la
préoccupation de la pérennité économique
des entreprises donc effectivement du
budget de la ville et moi tout
simplement ce qui nous a motivés avec
mes colistiers c'est la qualité de vie à
jean creux et donc ce qu'on souhaite
remettre au coeur du sujet c'est pour
les villes président aujourd'hui en fait
c'est il tire le meilleur
cauchy en fait de tout ce que peut leur
apporter la ville et nous l'avons vu
cette année en fait les enjeux ont
changé les préoccupations en changer et
donc nous devons quelque part nous faire
du bien les uns les autres en
encourageant en fait la solidarité en
dynamisant effectivement le local et en
gardant un cadre de vie apaisé et
apaisant pour que chacun puisse
s'épanouir en familles ou d'enfants dans
sa carrière professionnelle alors sur
les enjeux de la rentrée effectivement
il ya des enjeux par rapport à ce
chantier des eaux du moulin dont on qui
peuvent vraiment beaucoup de problèmes
et puis aussi l'été parce que beaucoup
de personnes ne sortirons ne pourront
pas aller en vacances comme d'habitude
les conditions seront différentes
donc là aussi nous souhaitons avoir
beaucoup d'artistes verriers la futilité
voilà donc nous souhaitons renforcer les
animations pour que les dunes provient
ce sens bien aussi l'été a dit le
prévenu s'est accrue stéphane mirambeau
de conclure ou d'aborder le thème de
votre choix
c'est avec de 30 buts ne paie pas
introduction c'est m en fait incroyable
que des candidats qui n'ont absolument
qu'ils ne gît rab sont pas la ville
essaie encore de faire un bilan et
d'attaquant adaptons personnes
quand on dit que l on veut gérer la
rentrée scolaire au heureusement que la
rentrée scolaire
elle est sur les rails et que tout est
déjà prêt parce qu'on est pratiquement
faite au mois de juin moi ce que je
tirais je suis suis ravi que la campagne
prenne fin parce qu'on a entendu
tellement de choses avec des gens qui
changent les programmes ont donc en
butte aux attaques des programmes qui
sont pas extraordinaires avec des
propositions plus belles les unes que
les autres et dont tout cela c'est vrai
qu'on peut se dire à un moment on
comprend quand les gens changent entre
le premier et le deuxième tour
on est un petit peu perdu un petit peu
dans le flou moi je terminerai pas par
un thème je terminerais simplement en
deux pendant quelque chose ou ville
provient et de se poser quelques
questions qui sont extrêmement simples
la première question c'est qui gère la
commune depuis 12 ans maintenant qui a
permis à villepreux de sortir de l'ombre
d'être aujourd'hui une commune connue
reconnue recherché qui gère la ville
seule depuis pratiquement un an et qui à
gérer seul la crise pendant plusieurs
mois on prenait les décisions immédiates
qui s'imposait en mettant en oeuvre les
mets
indispensable pour la poursuite du
municipaux moi je vous dirai juste la
réponse à toutes ces questions elle
extrêmement sain il ya une seule réponse
je vous laisse y réfléchir et j'espère
que vous garderez cela à l'esprit tout
simplement quand vous arriverez le 28
juin prochain sur la table vous aurez à
prendre un bulletin pour mais dans love
love voilà nous arrivons au terme de
cette émission un dernier coup d'oeil
aux temps de parole stéphane mirambeau
vous êtes à 10 minutes 38 jean baptiste
à monique dix minutes 44 10 minutes 39
pour valérie ben merci en tout cas à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat vous une émission bien sûr que
vous pouvez revoir en replay sur notre
site tv 78 points comme très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]